(theme chime)
- This week we are broadcasting
our shows in virtual reality
thanks to our good friends at AT&T.
That's right, you can watch our show in VR
via Conan cardboard and other VR devices.
We have four Conan 360 cameras
placed all over this theater.
You can see the show from any angle.
It's pretty impressive, show em Andy.
- Alright, strapping in.
- [Conan] Alright. (laughing)
- Alright, let's take it, oh, hi Conan.
- Yeah, hey Andy, how's it going?
- [Andy] Oh look at how big you look.
- [Conan] Yeah. (audience laughs)
- Let's cycle through the
cameras so people can see.
- [Conan] That's pretty impressive.
- Yeah, yeah, okay, there it is.
(audience cheers)
Get a little vertigo going.
(audience cheers louder)
Whoa, oh yeah, now this is a good way.
Hey buddy, what's going on pal?
(Conan and audience laugh)
Hey guy, how you doing?
- [Conan] Refuses to
acknowledge you in any way.
- [Andy] What's going on buddy?
- [Conan] Nope, refuses to
acknowledge you in any way.
- [Andy] Yeah yeah, hi friend,
what's your name, buddy?
- [Conan] Very nice. (audience laughs)
Clearly someone fleeing
the long arm of the law.
- [Andy] Someone's a little shy.
- [Conan] Someone who hasn't
paid taxes in 10 years.
- [Andy] Wait, go back to the
other one cause I wanna get--
- [Conan] Oh look at that!
- [Andy] Oh there's me!
- [Conan] Wow, yeah.
- [Andy] Aww, I could lose a few.
(audience cheers)
Well there you have it, this
is what you get to do at home.
Oh hi, you brought your luggage.
- [Conan] Okay, Andy you
look like an idiot. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- I do, oh my god, I
just saw myself, I do!
- [Conan] Yeah. (audience laughs)
Anyway it's as if you're in
the actual theater, Andy.
- It really is, it's so much more real
than actually being here.
- Yeah, now those of you
at home with headsets
can go to teamcoco.com/360 to experience
all of this if you like.
Thanks to our friends at
AT&T for sponsoring Conan360.
We're gonna take a quick
break, when we come back,
the cast of Silicon Valley is here!